cheap low carbon reliable energy must
sit at the heart of any modern economy
but Putin's indianization of
international gas prices has helped
Drive the cost of our national energy
consumption right up
this year we'll be spending an extra 150
billion pounds on energy compared to
pre-pandemic levels equivalent to paying
for an entire second NHS through our
energy bills
in 2019 a third of global emissions came
from energy Supply
so unless we act radically to change our
approach we'll both bankrupt our economy
and harm our planet
over the long term there's only one way
to stop ourselves being at the mercy of
international gas prices energy
Independence combined with Energy
Efficiency
energy Independence so neither Putin nor
anyone else can use energy to Blackmail
us
and Energy Efficiency to reduce demand
and climate impact as much as possible
now Britain is a global leader in
renewable energy last year nearly 40
percent of our electricity came from
offshore wind solar and other Renewables
since 2010 our renewable energy
production has grown faster than any
other large country in Europe
but we need to go even further with a
major acceleration of homegrown
Technologies like offshore wind carbon
capture and storage and above all
nuclear
[Music]
[Applause]
this will deliver new jobs Industries
and Export opportunities and secure the
clean affordable energy we need to power
our future economy and reach Net Zero so
today I can announce the government will
proceed with a new nuclear power plant
at size well soon
foreign
subject to final government approvals
the contracts for the initial
investments will be signed with relevant
parties including EDF in the coming
weeks
create 10 000 highly skilled jobs
and provide reliable low-carbon power to
the equivalent of six million homes for
50 years
700 million pound investment is the
first state backing for a nuclear
project in over 30 years and represents
the biggest step in our journey to
energy Independence
by Mr Speaker Energy Efficiency is just
as important
so today we set our country a new
National ambition by 2030 we want to
reduce energy consumption from buildings
and Industry by 15 percent
reducing Demand by this much means in
today's prices a 28 billion pound saving
from our national Energy bill or 450
pounds off the average household bill
this must be a shared Mission with
families and businesses playing their
part
but so will the government play our part
in this Parliament we're already
planning to invest in Energy Efficiency
a total of 6.6 billion pounds
today I'm announcing new funding from
2025 of a further 6 billion pounds
doubling our annual investment to
deliver this new National ambition